One example of a technique to actually improve the
ILP of the program is tree height reduction. Let's consider
a program that looks like this. Let's say that
we need a sum of these four registers in R8.
One way to get that is to add the
first two numbers into R8, and then add the second
number, and then add the third number and then
the fourth number. However, this forms a dependence chain because
we have the dependence here and the dependence here, so
really these instructions have to be done one after the other.
So tree height reduction works as follows. The compiler figures
out that instead of adding one number at a time to
the sum, and thus creating a chain of dependencies, what
we can do is we can group the computation this way.
Thus, getting, we first add the first two numbers and put
that in R8. Then we add the second pair of numbers,
put that in R7. And then we add up the R8
and R7 into our final result, R8. The dependencies here are
this and this. So, now we have two instructions that can
execute in parallel with each other because they don't depend on
each other. And then a third instruction that does depend on
them, too. So if this needed three cycles to execute, this
can actually execute in two cycles if we have a processor
that can do at least two instructions per cycle. Tree height
reduction can not always be done. It uses associativity of the addition
operation, and you have to keep in mind that not all operations are associative.
So we have to be careful. We can only do this when the
final result is the same as if we did things in the proper order.